bonjour à tous je me présente
christelle banon et
partager mon histoire à 14 ans je perds
mon père de manière brutale et cet
événement prématuré a changé ma vie
du jour au lendemain j'étais anéantie
par par ce qui se passait et je me
sentais peu soutenu par mes proches
il me disait écoute c'est la vie faut
rester fort mais moi moi j'en voulais à
la terre entière
j'étais habité par une grande colère
mais bon vu que c'est des épreuves de la
vie il fallait que je réagisse et j'ai
refoulé mes sentiments et j'ai fait
comme si je n'étais pas profondément
blessé je me suis même convaincu que
tout ce qui se passait dans la vie est
éphémère et dès qu'il fallait faire face
à une complication il valait mieux se
taire en tout cas c'est ce qu'on m'avait
appris alors quand par exemple un à
l'école je me contentais de la moyenne
et dès qu'il fallait faire face à mener
à mellac une barge esquiver ou toute
activité physique que je commençais
était arrêtée dès que ça me demandait un
effort un effort à faire
alors les années passent je deviens une
jeune fille plutôt heureuse bien entouré
mais j'avais une boule au ventre et je
comprenais pas je me suis dit peut-être
que c'est mon environnement qu'il
fallait peut-être envisager un nouveau
départ alors le bac en poche je
m'installe à montpellier pour poursuivre
mes études et vous retrouver dans une
ville qui m'était inconnu loin de ma
famille mes amis mes repères a été pour
moi une grande part a été pour moi une
épreuve
pourtant c'est ce que je voulais donc je
me suis quelques amis j'avais enchérit
mais dès que je me retrouvais dans mon
appartement
c'était l'enfer même à dix mille
kilomètres
j'avais encore cette boule au ventre moi
je pensais que la distance aller à les
soulager mes mots alors les mois passent
et je me sens de plus en plus mal je
suis constamment angoisse est stressé et
je développe une dépression du coup un
mois avant l'examen j'abandonne mes
études et je rentre à la réunion sans
prévenir ma mère arrivée à la réunion
je vois de la colère et de la déception
dans ses yeux et j'avais honte de moi il
fallait que je rattrape le coup
du coup je reprend les rênes de ma vie
je reprends mes études en alternance
je passe le permis et je m'achète une
petite voiture à partir de la maman
l'air ambiant sereine
moi ma dépression mais crise angoisse
son maître disparu et je rentre dans un
monde un peu superficielle un peu fait
tard et je fais la fête tout le temps du
lundi au dimanche je sortais tout le
temps puis un jour je me réveille avec
des douleurs abdominales
je vais consulter un médecin en ils
suspectent une gastro entérologue une
gastro ou une intoxication alimentaire
je lui donne raison avec l'hygiène de
vie que j'avais à cette époque sauf que
plus que les semaines plus que les
semaines passent je me sens enfin je
perds beaucoup de poids et j'ai des
douleurs mais atroce et surtout je vois
l'inquiétude de mes proches et surtout
celui enfin celle de mon grand frère
alors mon grand frère il est prêt à me
protéger de tout ce qui pourrait me
nuire mais là je le voyais à temps parce
qu'ils passent que m'arriver alors je
décide d'aller voir un gastro
entérologue je fais pas mal d'allers
retours dans son cabinet
au bout d'un mois me fait passer des
examens et là on me diagnostic une
maladie auto-immune chronique des
intestins un stade sévère en soit moi je
savais pas ce que c'était je pense que
j'allais prendre un médicament et puis
que ça irait mieux et là le médecin me
dit non en fait faudra prendre un
médicament à
une durée indéterminée et là je prends
conscience que je pouvais pas esquiver
cette ce problème c'était en moi quand
je décide de prendre ma santé au sérieux
et je vais consulter d'autres d'autres
spécialistes gastro entérologue d'été
titien micronutritionniste je me dirige
même vers une médecine naturelle et tout
ça m'a ramené à enfin en fait certains
me disaient que c'était ce genre de
maladies se développent quand on a un
choc émotionnel
quand on a une mauvaise gestion du
stress et d'autres juste que c'est
génétique
en gros la médecine avait du mal à me
dire la cause et moi je comprends je
commençais à comprendre que mon corps
mon envoyé un message du coup je me
lance à corps perdu dans les remet dans
les les conseils que teste les autres et
je les teste à nouveau mais sans même
poser me poser en faire la part des
choses
du coup on me conseille d'aller voir un
psy pour les sentiments refoulés et je
vais voir ce psy je lui balance tout je
lui dit tout mais sans même être
consciente de ce que j'étais en train de
lui dire on me conseille de faire du
yoga pour pour gérer mon stress
je fais du yoga j'y vais
jv pendant un moment mais j'étais même
pas conscientes des postures de la
respiration je faisais pas ce que me
disait de faire puis on me dit de manger
bio sans gluten sans lactose je manger
bio sans gluten sans lactose mais je
perdais le plaisir de manger en fait
puis aussi on me dit de mettre au
développement personnel pour entretenir
une pensée positive et tous les jours
j'étais là en train de décrire mais
gratitude mais sans même ressentir cette
gratitude
en fait pour une fois je voulais faire
les choses bien et j'avais l'impression
que toutes ces choses qu'on disait bien
n'était pas compatible avec moi après
c'est qu'il ya eu des résultats mais ce
n'était pas assez pour tout l'effort que
jeu déployé puis je commençais à être un
peu découragé et là mon frère me dit
écoute j'ai pris contact avec un
professeur spécialisé dans les maladies
chroniques des intestins et il est à
paris donc en juin on ira à paris
je suis dit ok démarre de façon faudrait
tester alors je tête enfin le je vais à
paris cet été jetés à paris et dès que
j'ai mis les pieds dans l'avion alors là
j'ai lâché prise et j'avais zéro
attentes pour
pour ceux souffrant d eau j'arrive à
paris je retrouve ma famille je profite
deux jeux je mange un peu ce que je veux
j'étais détendu j'étais bien puis ce
jour là où je rends compte ce fameux
professeur
alors après après analyse de mon dossier
ils demandent des examens
complémentaires et envisage l'arrêt du
traitement
alors là j'étais contente je m'attendais
pas qu'ils me disent qu'on allait
arrêter le traitement est en fait ce qui
dit juste après a changé mon mon ma
manière de penser
il a dit écoutez madame banon moi j'ai
confiance en votre corps mais j'ai pas
confiance en votre esprit es tu là
c'était la révélation je comprenais que
ma maladie s'était juste c'était enfin
c'est un indicateur de ce qui s'est
passé
enfin tu trouves à 10 passes et subit à
14 ans pendant toutes ces années j'étais
je n'habitais pas ce corps je vivais
mais dans un monde d'illusions
j'étais pas consciente de mon corps de
ma vie en fait alors rentrer à la
réunion j'avais un autre état d'esprit
j'étais déjà j'étais beaucoup plus
détendu et à part celle là je me suis
dit bon je vais refaire toutes ces
remèdes qu'on m'avait dit de tester afin
de faire je vais le faire mais avec avec
conscience alors je vais les revoir un
être petit et là je lui parle de tout ce
qui s'est passé dans ma vie et je prends
conscience des mots que je lui dis puis
je fais du yoga je me suis remise à avec
un autre un autre professeur et là je
suis consciente mais posture de beaucoup
plus concentrés jeu de enfin voilà ça
prenait un sens en fait pour moi je
mange je suis toujours attention à ce
que je mange je
je fais attention enfin je mens jeu
j'essaie d'éviter le lactose et le
gluten mais je prends beaucoup plus
plaisir à manger et 8 je continue aussi
à cultiver une pensée positive mais je
ne refoule pas les
les pensées dites négatives en fait tout
prenez un sens dans ma vie et j'étais
beaucoup plus présente dans ma vie en
fait alors tombé malade faisait
peut-être pas partie de mes plans mais
grâce à ma maladie j'ai appris à vivre
en pleine conscience et aujourd'hui ça
fait six mois que j'ai arrêté le
traitement et je me porte très bien et
pourtant beaucoup on dit c'était pas
possible mais comme quoi avec la volonté
on peut
et aujourd'hui si j'ai un truc à vous
dire si en tout cas vous pouvez retenir
cette phrase c'est ayez confiance en
vous et surtout décider avec conscience
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]